hello
and welcome to the reuben report direct
message i'm dave rubin on february 9
2021 and today it's a very serious day
in america the second impeachment
of donald j trump has begun
it is a very serious thing that we all
must take very seriously
because we all have no bigger problems
than donald trump
the guy who's no longer president no
longer on youtube
no longer on twitter facebook spotify
instagram
pinterest or anywhere else dealing with
that guy who's completely gone from
everything
is the thing that is the biggest problem
for all of us despite many of us not
having jobs
and all the other bad stuff that's
happening in the world
donald j trump the impeachment begins
today
just kidding guys it's actually not even
impeachment today what's happening today
is the dingbats in congress are debating
whether
impeaching a guy after he's out of
office
is even constitutional in the first
place so both sides are going to make
their arguments
to decide whether the impeachment trial
will move forward i suppose it will move
forward because it's sort of just the
best show in town even though nobody
wants to watch it
but nobody wants to watch the horror
show that's been the the two and a half
weeks
of the biden administration already so i
guess they're going to impeach the
president
who left peacefully who didn't turn out
to be
a fascist or hitler or any of the stuff
that they said he was going to be and in
many cases they
act much more like so i guess we're
going to go ahead and do that thing it's
complete nonsense nobody in the country
wants it
we have much bigger problems to deal
with but this
is what our elected officials have
decided to do
and they are a bunch of useless buffoons
hypocrites
and morons anyway we've got a great show
for you today i'm very excited to be
talking to you
uh and then tomorrow believe it or not
i'm heading to the free state
of florida that's right 10 days in the
sunshine and freedom
and fishing and beaches of florida i'm
very very excited
i am pre-recording today tomorrow's
episode of the direct message
which is a q a ask me anything q a which
actually if you want to submit questions
to you can do right now go to
reubenreport.locals.com oh you know
i'm off i'm off by a day my guys are
pointing out i thought i was going to
florida
the third tomorrow is live i am going to
florida tomorrow but i'm taping i'm
doing the live stream
live tomorrow but then later today i'm
taping
thursday's show which is the q a man my
if you saw what my calendar looks like
you would understand why i could get
confused by a day
anyway point is if you want to submit a
question for our ask me anything which
will air at 11 o'clock as usual on
thursday you can submit your question
right now at rubinreport.org
and before we get to all the stories and
yes we are playing another ronald reagan
clip from that interview and a ton of
you
i actually did look in the youtube
comments you guys totally dug it like
people actually want to hear
things from the past to help us frame
what's going on in the present so i am
going to do more of them for sure so we
got a great
clip amongst some other current event
type things
but before we get to any of that i want
to talk to you about built
bar it's february guys and if you're
looking forward to valentine's day but
not sure how to stay away from the candy
i've got just the solution for you built
bar is the secret to eating healthier
food while also eating tastier food
bill bars are low calorie low sugar high
protein high fiber great for the keto
diet you can actually lose or maintain
weight while indulging in a yummy treat
healthy has never been this delicious
bill bars taste like candy and come
in 18 amazing flavors like caramel
brownie and peanut butter you guys know
i dig the cookies and cream
bill bars are covered in 100 chocolate
include both nut and nut free flavors
and are soft and easy to chew
i know with restaurants finally opening
up even in this crazy town of los
angeles it'll be tempting to indulge but
we also need to shed those additional
quarantine pounds
which is why built bars are the perfect
alternative to pie for the health
conscious guy
each bar contains about 110 to 160
calories 16 to 20 grams of protein three
to five net carbs
guys it's only february don't give up on
your new year's resolution
built bar is the answer go to
builtbar.com
and use promo code ruben to get 20 off
your next order use promo code ruben to
get 20
off at biltmar.com and now back to me
all right so if you didn't see it on
sunday we had the super bowl this is
a a big football game that we've been
doing for i think around 75 years or so
a lot of people watch it this is usually
where the big commercials
are played and you might laugh at a
commercial they always try to be funny
this year it was a series of usually
depressing videos telling us how much we
hate each other and we have to be better
than that
and companies telling us that we should
wear masks and that things are horrible
and the world is ending and a lot of
depressing stuff
uh but the game was played tom brady won
his seventh super bowl which is just
completely insane and yes i will
go on the record as saying that tom
brady is at this
point the greatest team sport
athlete of all time probably at this
point surpassing
uh michael jordan michael jordan by the
way won was in six
nba finals and he was six for six in nba
finals tom brady
has won seven super bowls he lost three
so he was seven out of ten
but the fact that he left the you know
left the patriots
brings back gronkowski blah blah blah
i'm not doing a whole football show here
but you're not going to believe this
after the super bowl which was in tampa
bay i think it was the first time ever
but someone can correct me if i'm wrong
i believe it was the first time ever
that the home team
actually won the super bowl meaning they
always do the super bowl in warm weather
stadiums so it's very rare that one of
the two teams
in the super bowl will be where the game
is played
and you're not going to believe this the
people of tampa bay
florida after their home team won they
they celebrated
um crazy i know people were excited
young people were out there and they
were
drinking beer and high-fiving and
hugging
and dancing and shouting and celebrating
all things that are
highly illegal and immoral uh in these
these
repressive times that we live in uh and
the white house
jen pasaki you know i love posaki she
was asked
about what these horrible people did
after the super bowl let's take a look
yesterday the president or did the white
house have any concern
about what we all saw on a tv from tampa
about the thousands of people out
celebrating and without masks
any concern there certainly i mean the
president
i haven't spoken with him specifically
about the events of this weekend
but you know he did a psa yesterday
with dr biden making clear that social
distancing that mask wearing that
getting the vaccine when you have
the opportunity to get the vaccine are
vital steps to keeping
more americans safe and saving more
lives
and certainly we know the super bowl
looked not
like different from what it has in the
past and he
also conveyed that he's hopeful that
next year will be a moment where
everybody can celebrate
and party but he is of course concerned
when there
are pictures and photos we all are that
show
many many people without masks in close
distance
with one another at the height of a
pandemic don't worry guys
next year we hope that you'll be able to
celebrate and have fun and all that of
course
sure it was 11 months ago that we told
you two weeks to flatten the curve but a
year from now
then it will be okay possibly to
celebrate can't make any promises
i will give pasaki a little credit
because she did not circle back on the
question she just gave a sort of useless
answer but usually she just circles back
on every i don't know anything about
that i'll have to circle back
beyond that that's what she says and
then she gets very upset when youtubers
comment on it i have a feeling that
someone from the white house could be
watching this right now
oh my god that dave rubin said something
about jen pasagi um
look once again if you would like to
wear a mask
you should wear a mask and when i go
into places that require masks i do wear
a mask
i bought a piece of salmon yesterday for
dinner two pieces actually
and when i went into the supermarket i
put the mask on
i purchased the salmon and when i walked
out of the supermarket
uh i took the mask off to be totally
honest
because i don't really love wearing the
mask i find them a little irritating of
the ear
uh as i was crossing the threshold right
like right where the door the sliding
doors open and they close
just as i was getting through it through
the vacuum seal
i did take my mask off so there is a
possibility and
and if i have to pay a fine or whatever
it might be i may have spent as much as
one full second in a store without being
fully masked now
sure the air was a beautiful day it was
about 75 here in l.a not a cloud in the
sky and the air was blowing in but but
if
if in that moment and i can't even
confirm that i did it but i did take off
the mask and it was unclear if i had
just broken the seal or not so
you know i i'm i'm uh none of us are
perfect none of us are perfect nobody's
nobody's guilt-free and all of this
uh look if you want to wear a mask wear
a mask states have to figure out what
they're going to do and then within that
cities have to figure out what they're
going to do
so you know the mayor of tampa bay by
the way is is a woman who's a democrat
and she
had some weird video out there where she
was maybe talking about
having the police look into people who
weren't wearing masks and it's just like
is this really what we're going to do or
or is this the end of what a free
society looks like
when we're snitching on each other and
arresting each other and everything else
maybe maybe it is maybe it actually is
but i wanted to throw you a tweet too so
this is a tweet from quartz
uh and they had uh this to say with this
image now take a look at the image over
here because this is really something i
guess we're gonna have masks
in vending machines now sorry skittles
no more skittles now it's vending
machines
with more covet 19 variants extra
filtration isn't a bad idea
scientists are working to set global
standards for the myriad kinds of masks
available to help
help consumers but until then here's
what you need to know to make your own
masking decisions
i mean look again you should do what is
right for you and private businesses can
can set the rules for themselves and all
of those things
um but what i'm worried about more so
what me dave rubin is more so worried
about
is that the never-ending goal posts that
are moving we are just
whittling away our ability to make
decisions for ourselves we're just
pretending
that there's something above us that
knows what is good for us
and it's very obvious to me as someone
that lives here in california that does
gavin newsom really know what is best
for me or my life or or anyone that
lives in l.a or we've got a horrible
mayor here
eric garcetti it's like do these people
who've destroyed all of these businesses
when i drive down my main street and
everything's
boarded up because of the tolerant uh
black lives matter and antifa people and
the covet lockdowns and everything else
else and these giant buildings you know
giant office buildings that are just
completely empty
and the increasing homelessness and drug
use and all that we somehow there's
something about being a human that we
think that just because like something
exists above us that it's doing
something good for us
but do you really think these people
care about you anymore
i don't think so and do you think
they're doing it because
they they are just so worried about you
i i don't think so i don't think so i
think there's something else here
uh by the way the the recall gavin
newsom movement which
as you know i've been promoting the hell
out of it's we need less than a hundred
thousand votes
we're there we have till march 16th
there's over 1.4 of the 1.5
million so it's going to happen and my
hope would be that maybe that'll be the
first domino to fall
there will be a recall of one of the
worst governors if not the worst
governor
in the entire country and that that then
will
start other recalls it'll start legal
actions against people
who kept telling us to follow the
science
follow the science but we know right now
that when they put us in lockdown here
we had less cases than we have now but
it's politically expedient to slowly
open up because he got the election
results he wanted
for the presidency so here we are so
anyway i think you know my feelings
about all this so let's talk about
bambi.com people
when running a business hr issues can
kill you wrong term
wrongful termination suits minimum wage
requirements labor regulations
the list goes on and on and hr managers
salaries aren't cheap
at an average of seventy thousand
dollars a year bambi spelled b-a-m-b-e-e
was created specifically for small
business you can get a dedicated hr
manager
craft hr policy and maintain your
compliance all for just
99 a month with bambi you can change
hr from your biggest liability to your
biggest strength
your dedicated hr manager is available
by phone email or real-time chat
from onboarding to terminations they
customize your policies to fit your
business and help you manage your
employees day-to-day all for just 99
a month month to month no hidden fees
cancel any time
if you're like me then you know that you
didn't start your business because you
wanted to spend time on hr compliance
that is for sure
let bambi help get your free hr on it
today go to bambi.com
reuben right now to schedule your free
hr audit
that's bambi.com ruben spelled
bam to the be.com
reuben all right so i really wanted to
cover this story today because
as i keep telling you guys the bigger
issue than any of the political stuff
that's happening right now
is that we are starting to live in two
or three or four
or 500 different countries because
people
get information from different sources
and nobody knows what's true anymore
and we're told things like follow the
science and the people we disagree with
are suffering
from disinformation and we have fact
checkers
to solve all of these problems but then
we find out often that facebook or these
companies that they work with fact
checkers who are really just
activists and everything else well one
of the fact check
organizations that is thought of as
reputable like people will always say
well
what did politifact say about it
politifact okay
they've got the word fact right in the
name it must be must be good right i
mean you can't just put the word fact in
a name and then not be factual can you
well you can
uh politifact which is supposedly
reputable uh
they did a fact check on maxine waters
now let's throw up the tweet first
this is the tweet that they had of mac
about what maxine waters says this is
the official
blue check verified politifact twitter
account
no representative maxine waters didn't
say trump supporters
are quote not welcome here and then they
link to an article okay
now this is what they are saying is a
fact
now call me inspector gadget but we did
a little research around here we did a
little digging
and you're not going to believe this
guys we found something on the internet
and well just take a look
let's make sure we show up wherever we
have to show up
and if you see anybody from that cabinet
in a restaurant in a department store
at a gasoline station you get out and
you
[Applause]
[Music]
they're not welcome anymore anywhere
now the quote in the tweet here is not
welcome here she said they're not
welcome anymore
anywhere so that might be the tiniest
tiniest of technicalities but i think
the broader point here is a
they're a ridiculous organization
obviously and if you're referring to
them for your fact checking
um you're you're making a terrible
mistake um but did you listen to
everything else that she said there that
seemed if if words if not direct calls
for violence but just words can
instigate violence the way that they're
saying right now they're debating
whether trump is going to be post
presidency impeached right now because
of his words even though he did not call
for violence
well then what maxine waters said there
seems far more of a call to violence
than anything that i've ever heard trump
say if they're in a restaurant a
department store a gas station
create a crowd push back on them you
know let's play this again and tell me
if you've ever heard trump say something
that sounds like a direct sort of
ginning up of a crowd towards violence
or if especially
in that uh january 5th speech that he
gave where he was calling for peaceful
protesting as they're trying to impeach
the guy right now listen just listen
again to max words listen to the tone
what she's saying about her political
opponents etc etc
let's make sure we show up wherever we
have to show up
and if you see anybody from that cabinet
in a restaurant in a department store
at a gasoline station you get out and
you create a crowd
and you push back on them and you tell
them they are not
welcome anymore anywhere
they're not welcome anymore anywhere
these are your fellow citizens
and you should go up to them in
restaurants i mean now she didn't
directly call for violence i will
admit that she didn't say go up to them
and punch them but she's saying create a
crowd i mean it's clearly
to intimidate these people so let's just
be very clear about it if donald trump
is going to be impeached then this lady
should be in jail
right i mean again by their rules not
the rules of the laws of the united
states of the first amendment that
you're allowed to to speak and all of
these things but this is consistently
what they've done and then we know
cities burn down and then you get ali
velshi on msnbc with a building
exploding behind him
going they're mostly peaceful protesters
and by the way there's many many other
videos
of of not only democratic politicians
but also
members of the media uh calling for
violence
even more explicitly than that that
video of chris cuomo that i think you
guys have probably mostly seen where he
says where in the first amendment does
it say
protests have to be peaceful well it's
right there
first amendment yeah so you're condoning
violence because it's the kind of
violence
that you like i mean these these people
are all just terrible frauds they're
just
absolutely all terrible but but anyway i
didn't want to do that story to just
show you that vaccine waters is a fraud
and a food and by the way
maxine waters lives in hancock park
which is an ultra exclusive area
in la and what in i think about a six
million dollar mansion which i don't
begrudge her as long as she got all that
money legally although she's a
politician so
she probably didn't but she covers the
area
that i think has more to do with south
central l.a uh which is having all sorts
of problems in homelessness and blight
and everything else
she's but you know and she's been in
politics politics forever and
you know she's just it's just like a
perfect example oh can i get another guy
who's never done anything but got really
rich in the whole process
can i get them in government to fix it
because they'll really fix it by the way
i read that i read yesterday that trump
lost two billion dollars while being
president so you know make
that make of that what you may uh all
right i want to do the third story on
uh ronald reagan so if you didn't watch
the show yesterday i mentioned that when
i do cardio i usually watch old
basketball games but then i started
watching some old talk shows
and just different things of the past to
just kind of
get a better flavor at sort of what
people were talking about
in the 70s 80s 90s what was what was
sort of
relevant and accepted and everything
else and i came across this
incredible video of ronald reagan in
1975 now he had just wrapped up being
the republican governor of california he
was a democrat for most of his life
while he was in hollywood then he became
a california conservative when people
talk about california conservative where
you're a little more okay on the social
issues but you want to
you want a balanced budget you want
lower taxes you want more states rights
uh you believe in family things of that
nature that was sort of what the idea of
a california conservative i would say
that's very in line with
with the types of things i believe
anyway um
before he ran for president in 1980
the republicans were trying to figure
out what to do and reagan went
on johnny carson and they had about an
18-minute interview where carson
acted like an actual sort of unbiased
talk show host and just asked him what
his thoughts were
on everything and i watched this thing
and i was just so
overjoyed actually by the pleasantness
the sense of humor
the commanding of facts like everything
that reagan said here was just great so
yesterday i played a little bit of a
clip today we're going to play a little
bit of a clip and i'm going to keep
doing this sort of thing so that every
show isn't just about what's happening
today
it can be about what happened yesterday
and maybe that'll help sort of
frame what's going on today so this is
ronald reagan
on johnny carson tonight show all the
way back
45 years ago in 1946 years ago
in 1975. i think the answer to
curing inflation is a balanced budget
now
how do you do that i mean how do you
balance the budget
well balancing the budget is like
protecting you don't spend more than you
take in right
it's like protecting your virtue you
have to learn to say no
there's got to be another way
what's the second option well
no there's some ways that this could be
brought about first of all that
limitation here's another one
why shouldn't we have in addition to a
simplified income tax why shouldn't we
also have a law
that says that anytime a legislator a
congressman introduces a spending
program he has to introduce with it a
tax program to pay for it
then let the people find out there was a
woman that
uh from a financial firm that was back
at the president's economic council and
her words weren't quoted everybody
else's words got in the paper all the
hellers and the gull breaths and all the
so-called economists
and i had a i have a degree in economics
so i can say this i think an economist
is someone who has a phi beta kappa key
on one end of his watch chain and no
watch on the other
uh this woman said that you go to the
polls and you ask the people do they
want some social service some program
that government can give and the people
in the polls are apt to read and say
that sounds good yeah
but she says that isn't exactly accurate
she says put a
100 bill in each person's hand
and then show them the program and say
now isn't that a nice program do you
want it
give me the hundred dollars and she says
see what the poll says then and
how many people hang on with a hundred
dollars instead of the program
in other words it was rather hidden and
someone doesn't know exactly where it's
gonna come
they all start all the government
programs start a dollar down and we'll
catch you later
and and they they multiply all of those
things that you would
the office of management and budget in
washington that's responsible for the
budget putting up putting the budget
together
cannot even tell you how many boards
commissions agencies bureaus and
departments there are in the federal
government
but all of them can pass regulations and
those regulations have the force of law
and the difference is when you break the
law you're innocent until proven guilty
when you break a regulation the fellow
that charges you with a break in the
regulation
you're guilty right if you want to take
him to court and prove you're innocent
that's up to you
god tell me that is just not spectacular
and also
calming did you feel a little calmer
actually when you're listening to him i
mean the tone of his voice he has
he has a great calming soothing way of
speaking everything his demeanor the way
he's sitting there with his legs crossed
the way
you know he has a couple sort of zingers
and the way he uses humor to describe
these things um but there there was just
so much there
and he's in some ways he's even talking
about things that that we're talking
about now
with without even really fully knowing
what the future was going to bring
although i suppose that maybe he did
because
things the government just kept
expanding but when he talks about the
office of management and all the
regulations they can pass and they don't
know how many offices there are and
everything else
what's he talking about he's talking
about the deep state he's talking about
that there are all of these governmental
agencies that just grow and grow and
grow and grow and get bigger budgets and
they just remain there forever and they
can do all the stuff and nobody knows
who's part of it in essence he's talking
about the deep state i mean that's
something we've sort of talked about
over the last couple years but the first
line there was just spectacular
when carson asks him like how do you
balance the budget balancing the budget
is like protecting your virtue you got
to know when to say no
when i heard that the other day i
thought man he's channeling jordan
peterson
except this is a little bit before
jordan peterson right jordan peterson
was about
was about 20 when this thing came out
something like that or maybe 15 or so
um really interesting though balancing
the budget is like protecting your
virtue you got to know when to say no
but no one in the government ever says
no to anything why would you be the guy
in the government to ever say no to
anything you know you'll never get voted
in right because people
are mostly idiots because our education
system is stupid so they don't think
anything through
which is why the the story that he told
about the woman
with the hundred dollar bill is so
interesting because it's like everyone
is always like oh yes we want more
programs we want more stuff give us more
stuff and if you look at all of the
the little um additions when you go into
the voting booth and they've got all the
things that they want to pass and it's
like do you want 500 billion dollars for
more schools and you're like yes
i don't know well then you have to
really realize oh do you realize that's
going to take
money to do and even if we don't take it
from you specifically though we will
we have to take it from somebody and if
we keep taking it from those people they
might leave the state you think that has
a little something to do with why
california is so whacked
at the moment but this idea that if you
handed them the hundred if you say to
them okay do you want the program
and everyone says yes because it just
sounds good but they don't know where
the money comes from but then if you
hand them the hundred and then you're
gonna say but i gotta take that hundred
back because we're gonna do that thing
that you said you really wanted well
then no one would do it and we really
understand this and if you want a
perfect
really just a perfect real world
happening right now example of this
uh just yesterday in the last couple
days you know that the the democrats
have been pushing this 15
minimum wage thing this 15 federal
minimum wage
now of course it sounds right would we
like
people the poorest people who have
minimum wage jobs to make more money it
kind of sounds right
but you can't just artificially inflate
how much someone is going to be paid
because then the cost of everything will
go up if the guy who's flipping fries at
mcdonald's who's a
you know a 16 year old kid after work if
you force him to pay 15
then mcdonald's is going to say okay
we're going to increase the price of the
dollar menu and now the dollar menu is
no longer the dollar menu it's the 250
menu right
i mean these are basic economic
principles i would highly recommend
that you watch any video or read any
book by thomas all i mean
you'll get this stuff it doesn't you
know they try to confuse you with all of
like their fancy lingo and it's like go
to somebody who can explain something
cleanly
and clearly to you but we all know this
if you were running a business right now
uh and you had like somebody that you
needed to come in and clean some stuff
up or do some stuff that wasn't highly
technical highly skilled you might get a
younger person for it
and you wouldn't you would figure out
what it's worth paying them
and then they would decide if it's worth
taking that job and if they didn't take
it
somebody else would and that freedom
allows people to make more decisions for
themselves and actually keeps
costs down the less regulation and
less taxes that i have here in
california
the more i can do for my team right the
more you increase that stuff
well then the less that i can do for my
team so i pay my guys full benefits 100
for their for themselves dental medical
100 they don't pay a dime in and for
their dependents
and i'm more than happy to do it if the
government comes in and takes more money
for me well then i may have to look at
that
and be like all right guys i got to take
some of this stuff away and then they
have to pay for it
so these are these are basic concepts
that we don't really think of we think
oh
bernie wants to give us 15 an hour but
bernie
sanders has never run anything he is a
politician
who's only just taken money from people
to do a bunch of nothing
anyway i think you get it i like that
ronald reagan guy
i'm not exactly sure why a lot of people
didn't like him he also fought communism
i don't like communism do you like
communism that isn't to say he did
everything perfectly i know there were
some scandals in iran contra and a bunch
of other stuff
okay that's fine but i thought you know
watching that it's like
we can get back to something sensible
but
who would be the type of sensible person
that you just saw there in ronald reagan
who would be television ready
who who would want to put it all out on
the line again who would want all of
that risk
and and to be part of such an evil
machine like who would do it
and in a way i don't think you get
someone like a ronald reagan that we saw
there in 1975 i think the only way you
can get it in a weird way
is like a donald trump someone whose
personality
is different right like somebody who is
going to fight back in a crazy way and
how are we going to combine those two
things
to f like someone who will fight but
also have all of the information
and the decency and desire for the right
reasons and all of that like how are we
going to find
that person i don't know how we're going
to find that person although it does
remind me
of an episode of gi joe from around 1986
when you know after a couple years of
cobra commander's poor leadership and
boy that guy just got them into a lot of
trouble and they could never beat the
joes
what did dr mindbender do well dr
mindbender said okay i'm going to find
the dna
of some of history's best leaders he
went for a lot of evil people genghis
khan
that type of person napoleon et cetera
he took their dna it was a crazy
five-part episode
found their dna and then he put them all
into a cloned body and what did he do he
created serpentor but then serpentor had
problems too
anyway i think you see what i'm saying
here guys it ain't gonna be easy but i'm
in it with you
have a great day everybody uh we're live
tomorrow at 11 a.m
and then as i said we've got a q a which
i'm taping today
so if you want to get your questions in
for thursday's q a go to
reubenreport.locals.com and by the way
uh part one
with my of my interview with ayan
herciale who is just
like the best of the best you want to
see somebody
who is who is brave and decent and
good check out my interview with ion
part one is up on youtube right now
uh the full episode is already up ad
free at reubenreport.locals.com
uh have a great day everybody and if you
haven't seen it check out that five part
uh gi joe episode the creation i think
it's called rise serpentor sir
i think it's called rise serpentor rise
and you'll see a lot that'll make a lot
of sense to you all right that's it
adios